did you have doubts about your own
mathematical ability or your own
that if whether or not you could not
that you wanted to maybe i'm sure you
had doubts should i go into this but
could you did you have the ability so
did you ever doubt your own ability big
time big time
yeah big time and i remember i um in
fact i remember when i was a graduate
student i knew i was deeply
interested in the big questions and i
but i actually
was gonna settle for less and because
internally i didn't didn't feel i had i
had what it took and everybody else was
just really mathematical and i really
knew
things that i could i didn't know and i
felt it was going to be such a learning
curve
um and i remember one time
um
um
that we had this visitor
um that had to come visit brown's
physics apartment
and um
he was of you know he was like one of
the most brilliant strengthers and he
carried himself as if he was some kind
of guru i mean we used to walk a walk
like i was like is this guy some kind of
yogi or something his uh and his name is
sumet das right i need to come visit um
the strength theorists at brown and he'd
be there and we
and he'd be there on on on weekends and
one day i was in you know hanging out
and i
he started talking to me and i was like
why is this strength here is talking to
me
um
and i i then i asked him i said i felt
comfortable i was like is that something
that like you know if you want to do
string theory
um how good you do you need to do this
he goes no no no all you have to do is
be passionate about it and just go for
it and and somehow the way he said it to
me made me feel like well maybe i can do
this right
so i definitely i i owe i definitely
want to give i owe it to submit das you
know for for kind of playing that role
just saying hey you can do this
um
but you know that that still lives at me
that still looks at me i still feel
like i yeah i
you know my strengths are not with um
[Music]
you know knowing a whole bunch of math
although i love math and i love learning
from mathematicians and i you know um
you know there's a place
where we play we have to play on our
strengths and know what they are in my
case i'm you know kind of intuitive i
have pictures i play with thought
experiments
it's important to talk to people to have
sound boards and one of the things
that's very important to me is actually
having some boards that are not always
experts in my field
yeah
so i find things like this to be very
useful also to my research like
conversations like this
you're doing a service to physics
research
thank you thank you so what age was that
when you
met with a guy summit i believe his name
is summit das
yes sumit das i was a first year
graduate student
and i was actually trying to be an
experimentalist at the time
not not because it wasn't um
experimental experimental work is as
hard or even harder than um than theory
work so
that's the asterisk for brian keating
yes exactly um
but um
i guess what i'm saying was that it was
a time where what my real interests were
i was suppressing it um
because i didn't think
so yeah it was
i don't know i think i was like 24 23
years old
i'm 50 now so yeah what advice do you
have because there are quite a few
people who are watching this who don't
have a background in university maybe
they have some training in mathematics
but that's it maybe some rudimentary
physics that they've seen from an mit
open courseware
video
but they want to understand
string theory m theory well string m
theory and loop quantum and so on
but they don't feel like they have it in
them let's the average age of this
person who emails me this or leaves
comments about this tend to be 20 30 and
even 40. so i'm not sure if the age
differences give yield different advice
yeah
um i would say you know look if you
can't um
basically
yeah that's a that's a really good one i
mean it depends on you know whether or
not you can maybe
go back to some kind of school but there
are lots of you know online
presence now information online
like um i'm thinking about even things
like
lenny suskin's course
um
but even like one thing i find really
interesting is that the perimeter
institute has um online they have made
um opens
they've made their online seminar series
jump in like listen to these seminars go
online
the other thing is um there are some
really good books now so for example
like lenny suskin has a book called
theoretical minimum
which i endorse the second i mean
they're really good i read them actually
you know um it's a good place to kind of
be you know sort of build some
foundation
and then
actually go online and pull out some
problem sets and try playing working
with these problem sets and get up you
know join a group of friends and work
for these problem sets together
i mean practicing problems the reason
why you want to practice things like
problems that have been solved already
is that
you build an arsenal of of solve
problems and they they can be used as
as a
launch pad to solve and solve problems
right so kind of getting a sense of
what's what's been solved out there and
then i actually recommend
one of the reasons why actually and this
is not an advertisement i literally
wrote my second book
um
precisely because i wanted to
um
i wanted to um
um
fill a vax of a vacuum
in terms of how people can start
thinking about research problem what
what are the cutting edge things that
we're thinking about now
and it was written very much in the
spirit of richard feynman's um you know
character physical law and brief his
brief history of time to kind of carve
some space out exactly for that for that
person who wants to get a sense of
what's out there you know what what are
people thinking about and what are the
unsolved problems and what are the
directions that people are afraid of or
is you know um is holding the field back
from again from the opinion of a
you know so in other words imagine i'm
somebody's thesis advisor right
um like a phd thesis or a master's
thesis advisor and i and i
had to disappear for a year i would
leave this book with with that
thesis student right
so those are three things three three
concrete things get your book get what's
the book the name of the book and do you
have it right in front of you i don't
have that i just gave my book away to a
student of mine uh okay
yeah the book is called fear of a black
universe an outsider's guide to the
future of physics that's the subtitle
now when i hear that to me it sounds
like a book about race and science is it
a book about that or exclusively about
that or minorly about that minorly about
that i'll say 10 percent of the book is
about
is about um identity in science um of
course we can include race in that but
we can include personality different
modes of ways of thinking
um you know
but the title was also a play it was a
you know it was a was a nod to one of my
favorite rap bands when i was in college
called public enemy
that's something you and i also have in
common not only are we from trinidad but
we used to rap although i think he used
to do the beatboxing i was more of a
beatbox than a beat maker i i wish i
could rap so at one of these days we
might have to do something together
that'd be great wouldn't it yeah yeah
okay how was the process of learning for
you changed now that you're older what
would if let's imagine you could advise
your young self practices to keep
practices to drop practices to adopt
you're advising your 20
maybe even 25 30 year old self
about what though about learning
something like string theory or learning
something like oh
yes yes yes yes i think
it's important
to combine practice with play
um so rather than you know if i you know
if i'm learning something like the
the the equations of motion
coming from varying the string world
sheet action
for example
it's important that i not only know how
to correctly vary the oil in the ground
you know how to obtain the oil lagrange
equations
all right
and why the calculus of variation
applies that applied for a point
particle would also apply for a string
world sheet action
but it's important that once i get this
that i play with those equations i
literally play with them i move them
around i play with the rules of the map
i break the you know i actually break
the rules and see what happens like the
same way a kid plays with a toy
what would be an example of trying to
break the rule
just making a mistake or what or making
a purposeful mistake and seeing where it
leads yeah make it literally make a
purposeful mistake and see where it
leads exactly
that's interesting um yeah so
i'm one for
playing with breaking the equation
breaking the the equations um well you
know you know kids don't try it at home
so but this is definitely something you
can try at home and
[Music]
you might learn something but when you
go out and you give a talk or you write
up you try to write a paper you're
obviously not going to
put that mistake there
but it's you do these things just to see
you know um
again that's kind of like yeah that to
me is just like you know the idea of
playing with with um with things